horror films are supposed to get your
adrenaline pumping but for some these
thrills are just too much to handle it
may sound like a clever bit of marketing
but physical reactions to these movies
have indeed required medical
professionals to treat moviegoers at the
hospital or the scene of the scare here
are a few films with fictional frights
intense enough to cause real-life
physical trauma The Exorcist let's start
with a classic if you've never seen the
Exorcist then you've probably never
known true cinematic or still shocking
by even today's sensibilities the film
had quite an effect on people who first
saw it in 1973 local news reports from
the time mentioned people crying
throwing up and even fainting we have a
lot of people throwing up and a lot of
people shuddering but the thing that
really surprises me as people faint I
mean I've never in my life known a movie
where people would do think the Exorcist
may have been the first but it certainly
wasn't the last for example good night
mommy
an Austrian film about ten-year-old twin
boys whose mother has just had facial
reconstructive surgery doesn't sound all
that scary but once mommy comes home all
bandaged up she seems to be a wholly
different person and exudes a cold
severe aura while 2015's good night
mommy is mostly a psychological horror
the latter half of the film is full of
violence and some people can't handle it
in an interview with indieWIRE the
director says early screenings proved
the filmmakers were onto something
saying quote two people fainted that's
the best compliment we've had so far
bite have you ever heard the one about
the woman who turned into an insect
after getting bit by one well that's the
premise of the 2015 body horror movie
bite and the impact it had on moviegoers
is no joke at the Fantasia International
Film Festival premiere audience members
were given barf bags as a gag but some
people reportedly had to make use of
them that's not all first and no reports
a few people even passed out in the
theater and at least one ambulance was
called to the scene saw three by the
time we got around to the third saw in
2006 you'd have thought fans would have
built up a tolerance to all the gross
violent images from the first two films
obviously this was not the case as the
BBC reported that moviegoers in a few UK
theaters fainted and emergency services
were called out three times in one night
because of the film a woman in her 20s
even needed to be hospitalized after
apparently fainting with fright while
others were treated at the scene
raw the 2016 cannibal film raw premiered
at the Toronto International Film
Festival and wasted no time in making
film goers faint and vomit The Guardian
reported that paramedics had to be
called in because the realistic biting
and chewing of human flesh hosts all the
gory lacerations and wounds were all too
much for some audience members who
fainted in their seats so not a good
choice for dinner and a movie the green
inferno another cannibal movie capable
of getting folks to faint is Eli Ross
the green inferno which features a group
of activists who crash land in a jungle
and have to survive captivity at the
hands of a cannibalistic tribe par for
the course for an Eli Roth movie the
green inferno is full of graphic images
gratuitous gore and body mutilation oh
and of course all the people eating
can't forget about the people eating an
article on New Zealand's news hub said a
woman fainted during a screening in
France
Ross shared the news and Instagram
clearly thrilled by the glowing review
The Human Centipede two movie lines Jen
Yamato wrote about her experience at the
premiere of The Human Centipede - a
fantastic fest in 2011 and how festival
founder Tim league joked about there
being EMTs on hand in case people got
sick like the barf bag gag at the bite
premiere this joke ended up being less
funny when it came true the person
sitting next to yamato filled two barf
bags and eventually fainted and two
ambulances were called to the scene to
tend to audience members VHS an
anthology of scary stories that debuted
at Sundance 2012's VHS certainly had an
effect on viewers of the festival the
first night a woman left the theater in
tears because she reportedly couldn't
stand the tension and suspense and
according to co-writer Simon Barrett
paramedics had to treat two audience
members at a midnight screening who
suffered seizures and started vomiting
that sounds awful but the good news is
that these two troopers decided to go
back and finish the film anyway which is
just about the best review a horror
flick can get thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]